[Music]
so we are putting together a
battlegrounds live action action short
for the corridor channel and it's a
byproduct of that we needed to get every
single battlegrounds gun in airsoft form
because we don't use real machine guns
on set it's really expensive
and hard to come by
as you might know if you watch our
videos we recently got a 3d printer you
can do a lot of stuff with the 3d
printer from printing up little
tchotchkes that are going to eventually
go in the garbage can to actually
printing out functional prototypes and
actual equipment that you can use to be
truly productive
i'm going to split the difference
between those two things i want to try
making a mask i want to learn how to
print something like this out of
something like that let's see if i can
do it and not totally mess it all up so
i was doing some research online and
there's a whole bunch of 3d printed
masks out there so it definitely seems
possible and you can see they're
actually broken up into a lot of pieces
usually and printed out like on this
mask here for example you can see all
the different chunks when you're
printing things need supports so if you
have like say a large arch printer needs
something to lay down the plastic on so
it'll create a little support up the
middle so that's another reason for
splitting up these masks into these
separate pieces it seems pretty
straightforward it seems like something
i could figure out i'm thinking
of starting
with this red hood helmet because it's
super basic and it's on thingiverse
there's a whole bunch of different
models in thingiverse it's really cool
people share their creations now he's
actually divided it into a lot of
individual pieces and i know our printer
is bigger than these pieces i think it's
going to be simpler for me and i'll have
a cleaner helmet i can actually cut it
up into newer pieces and not only that
it'll help me learn how to split like
slice up any other mask that i make for
printing so i'm going to disregard all
his individual pieces here that he's cut
up and i'm going to
instead take his full mask model i'm
going to re-cut it myself hopefully not
screw this whole thing up
so here we are with a collection of
every single gun from battlegrounds
minus a couple very very key exceptions
because they don't make airsoft versions
of them
so let's jump in
all right so in pubg there's a couple
very specific rifles that you'll find
all over the place the scar the m4 the
m16 and the akm it's worth knowing that
this is not the ak-47 but the akm they
look very similar but the acam is the
slightly modernized version of the ak-47
rm16 has an underslung grenade launcher
of course in the game they don't have
grenade launchers but something that's
worth noting is that the m16 has a
longer barrel length an airsoft that
usually translates into more accuracy
however i'm personally a fan of the m4
form factor in airsoft because it's very
very interchangeable and very very
customizable i actually have another m4
here i didn't pull this one out because
it's not the same color as the one in
the game but you can see here it's
actually kitted out with all the fixins
including the two-time scope
so here we have the m249 and the
thompson submachine gun commonly
referred to as a tommy gun you probably
guess why but in the in the game they
gave you 100 rounds and a drum mig drum
migs are neat in an airsoft game i just
use a high cap regular looking meg the
m249 is a really cool rifle it's huge
it's heavy there's a lot of little parts
and believe it or not this isn't even a
carrying handle it looks like it is but
it's not personally if i were to play
with one airsoft i play with a scar i
actually have a personal scar with an
extended barrel that i play with and it
is one of my favorite airsoft guns
[Applause]
good news the pewter 42 shirts are still
on sale on the quarter digital store at
quarterdigital.com
store and newsflash we now are selling
these in baseball style teas by popular
request they are there go check them out
limited time only okay so here i have
the red hood helmet loaded up in 3ds max
the very first thing i had to learn was
how to slice this stuff up so there's
actually a modifier in 3ds max called
slice so when you apply slice it creates
a plane here and it just straight up
slices your object now the thing is it
doesn't cap it so there's another
modifier you can put on here called cap
holes
which also does exactly what it says it
does and there you have it so this is
one easy way to slice up an object and
all you have to do is duplicate your
object and without moving the slicer at
all you can choose which side is being
sliced you can easily make two separate
slices that perfectly meet at the seam
so here we have the mask all sized up
you can see all the different sections
here my thought is as i print these i
can lay them down on the bed so they
basically just get printed upwards and i
don't need a lot of support material i
have another thought here a problem i
could encounter so i thought it might be
a good idea to add like little ridges
that can like guide the mask into the
right spot so i went ahead and i modeled
all those here so i have a little ridge
here that i put on the side i did a
little loft shape and i booleaned out
the top edge of the mask so it's
perfectly cut out and so then i have
another one right here on the bridge of
the nose oh i have one right here on the
bottom front of the mask which will
bring the two halves together
so we're going to start with printing
this section right here
so what this program does is it takes a
3d model and it turns it into paths for
the printer which is called g-code i
guess so it's going to tell the little
printer head where to move and which
steps to take and all that kind of stuff
all right so i've finished orienting the
mask on this platform here anything
that's red is a part of the print that
needs support so i have a little bit of
stuff on the bottom there that needs
support and the underside of this eye
all right so yeah that's the print of
support all the way up the front of the
mask there and if i go in and i zoom in
close here you can actually see all the
individual paths
of plastic that are going to get laid
down and it's a very very fine print all
the different tracks
little plastic heads going to take it's
really neat so i hope this works i'm a
little worried about this little support
stand because the supports are made out
of like just one thin wall of plastics
you can just pop them off easily
okay but this is pretty efficient i
think this will work and i if this works
i know that the mirrored side of this
will also work no sweat
okay let's print it all right so let's
talk about some smgs that are in pubg
first and foremost my favorite smg in
battlegrounds is the vector and this is
actually my favorite smgs that we have
here in the studio this is a gas powered
kwa vector
kwa no longer has the license to
manufacture vectors chris the company
that makes the vector actually makes aeg
vectors now so you can go and you can
get an airsoft vector it's not gas
powered it's electric from the company
that actually makes the vector now this
is a rare spawn actually in the gay man
in real life and it's that color in the
game too this here is a micro uzi it has
the shoulder stock on it which you have
to find in the game to attach to it so
if you're ever wondering how big the
micro uzi actually is it's this big kind
of micro not that micro oh it's also
it's not pronounced oozy it's pronounced
this is the ump this is one of my other
favorite guns everybody just secretly
the ump is a favorite gun pubg they
might not know it but it is it's
basically a poor man's rifle i mean look
how big it is
see
they're almost the same size so the
pistols in the game m9 got the 1911 and
the glock 18 which this is the closest
thing i have
much like the chris vector glock also
limited the ability for manufacturers to
use their gun design i personally
actually run with a 1911. i have this
we 1911
that's never broken
i've used it in every game
and i love it
[Music]
to say the mistakes you learn from
aren't actually mistakes right well
maybe i can make this not a mistake by
learning from it let's see um it's all
messed up it shouldn't be hairy like
this i'm not trying to print a bunch of
pubes here here's what i think happens
it's like it's like csi from 3d modeling
this little guy didn't stick to the
plate and broke off and so it kept
trying to print this stuff here without
the support support wasn't there anymore
and that's why you have all this
squiggly stuff in here too but i can fix
this i can fix this i just need to make
a bigger skirt and it kind of makes
sense this whole thing is really tall
and the skirt's only this big a bigger
base would probably make sense
so i'm going to increase the size of the
skirt and repeat it again
all right shotguns it breaks my heart
but they don't make over under airsoft
shotguns i guess no one ever saw the
point in making a
brake loading
over under shotgun for airsoft that
fires two bullets i had this remington
870 stand in to give the effect
it does that which is really cool
there's airsoft shotguns that basically
are just regular rifles that shoot one
or two bbs but in terms of one that
shoots out a cloud of bbs if you want
something like that your best bet is
actually to go with a grenade launcher
because those are the closest things to
shotguns in airsoft all right sniper
rifles so we got the couple sniper
rifles from the game here's the awm
here's the m24
and everybody's favorite gun to hate the
vss the vss is cool because it comes
with a silencer and a four time scope
mounted on it in the game in real life
doesn't come with a four time scope
however the bullets are subsonic they
shoot nine millimeter rounds this was
supposed to be a stealthy spec ops like
spetsnaz gun it was designed for them to
carry with them behind enemy lines when
they shoot it the subsonic bullets
prevent there from being a little sonic
boom that little crack of a bullet
flying by you you won't hear the bolts
fly by it's a good gun for annoying
people and confusing them in
battlegrounds and when it comes to
airsoft it shoots at the same speed as
everything else so it really doesn't
matter
this is the m24 and it's been decked out
from various uses and videos that we've
had it in with a bipod and a rag
it's our real janky awm not a bad gun
actually for airsoft if you're going to
play with sniper rifles in airsoft
you're kind of better off having like a
game with custom rules where it's like
pistols and shotguns and sniper rifles
only otherwise realistically at the end
of the day anybody using an electric aeg
is going to
be more or less just as accurate as
somebody with a sniper rifle i also have
this really cool looking customized awm
this is from our battlefield series this
was customized by the folks over at
evike.com and evik helped hook us up for
some of these props for this upcoming
battlegrounds video that we're making so
a big thank you to them and if you guys
want to get any of these guns for your
own kit go check them out they have all
these guys here and what about the
crossbow the one the one last outlier of
a gun
if you shot your friends at the crossbow
you'd probably kill them
we have this old hand prop crossbow here
it actually does does shoot
i think i need new strings
there we go
oh that face
printed a bigger skirt it totally worked
this little piece here didn't break off
this time so it's on here like this and
when i found it there's like some weird
like fuzzy stuff here
and there's this line
all the way across the mask all the way
across here and this piece actually
broke off
something got fudged but here's what i
think happened i don't think i loaded
the plastic filament correctly and i had
a feeding issue something happened here
where it got caught and it wasn't
feeding plastic for an entire like two
or three layers of print so now there's
a freaking line
across the model and this piece broke
off and there's a line right here and
there shouldn't be and this is about 10
hours into it
[Music]
you